hello and welcome deep inside the film
room where we will begin just make the
cover you've been waiting you looked at
it make the comment oh no I wasn't I was
just looking at your spocky and
shoulders and your tropical shirt you
have on that's what I'm waiting for
Tropic Thunder oh so good so good what
do you guys what he goes you like it and
I go simple comment yeah it sorry I'm
used to him by now I like it I like that
you know what I like what I like a
crewneck sweater distracts from your
face let's do that what movie is that
from I don't remember your like do you
like my dress and then that takes the
attention away from your face I rely or
liar
oh yeah what do you like can't lie and
that comes about by qierre yeah I've had
better
ah that movie was amazed it's great the
pan is blue we are a little bit fired up
and I think the reason we're fired up is
we've reached the point of the year
where the hot takes are coming in
boiling boiling you're watching the film
and people like to talk about things
like numbers numbers you know what I
felt this week yeah I felt the wrath of
Giants fans oh gosh we took my giant fan
we took that rant of me going off on Eli
say and sell the dream it's over and I
don't know where these people came from
I mean every time i refresh my mentions
it's someone telling me about his 90
percent 90 quarterback rating or how
he's currently the 12th rated
quarterback in football yeah that's the
problem that's truly the problem and
that's why the quarterback rating is a
[ __ ] stat and it's also what he's
playing for for that argument right
there I mean if you broke it down to me
the Manning's are political that is what
they would do yeah you wrote in your
notes which we're gonna get to later you
said oh look you got a hundred yards of
garbage yards at the end so guaranteed
right and I'm not gonna take any chances
I'm not gonna actually make a throw to
try to win the game I'm just gonna keep
checking it down yeah and at the end of
the game and a week or so everyone's
gonna go Eli wasn't that bad in that
game no when the game was competitive he
was horrible
I don't know what other way to say I've
never seen something so simply with my
I that I don't know what other people
are watering blinded by love Sims went
in Dovan to the notes we're gonna have a
full Eli breakdown we're gonna have a
full mahomes breakdown we're gonna
explain what's happening in Atlanta
Cincinnati Dallas Detroit New Orleans is
starting to come along a little bit
Baltimore and Pitt you did a lot of work
this week thank you did it feel good I'm
tired leave me alone that is good
if you you know what actually I found
myself sitting there watching film this
week going okay I think I'm starting to
understand these teams oh you see we've
said this on the show which aired last
night Wednesday 8:00 p.m.
little Pat McAfee action George Kittel
Trent Taylor the losses were awesome but
one thing that we started the show with
was you're noticing the clown ease the
kumaras the Ezequiel Eliot's the guys
that didn't play in the preseason now
they're in game shape right in week four
week five yeah so do you think that this
is what we do every year we throw out
the first few games yeah
the coaches are now having tape Bill
Belichick and Scout so which teams do
you really think you know right now whoa
okay let's make a little general yeah
let's pull up the teams yeah
the teams I know right off the bat okay
the NFC's pretty easy okay I feel like
the Rams and the Bears I know them okay
what do you know about him
well I know that the Rams are so
explosive on both sides of the football
and it's just extremely creative you're
not gonna really ever stop that offense
you're just gonna have to hope to make
something happen make a play do
something that fools them to maybe one
or two plays a game you can change and
dictate the game and that can stay
consistent the whole year yes I do
just with the talent level the way golf
is playing and then kid genius being
there is the head coach yes and the
Bears the Bears I think it's arguably
the best defense in the sport I think
they're in that conversation they have a
good offensive line where they can run
and the off the passing game and the
creativity is coming along with Mitchell
true Biscay to where i have again
they're not blowing my you know doors
off with all their creativity yet and
I'm sure Matt Nagy's offense is not
completely installed but you see a
little bit of every week every week yeah
oh there's a Taylor Gabriel out of that
there's a new formation right all those
who read Cohen love that guy exactly who
else do you think you know any I think I
know New Orleans look I think New
Orleans last week their defense a game
plan which we'll get into I think
they're shoring up some things there and
there oh line is now getting into shape
there a line return to form yes and I
just feel like yes I just feel like
they're going to be what we thought they
were mark Ingram's exactly he's also the
thing is this I would say the Falcons
and Saints have a had a very similar
start to the year
yeah Falcons started off slowly put up a
lot of points in weeks two and three
right st. started off slowly came back
still the difference is the Saints got
wins
yeah the Saints are three and one sister
one in three right you know and wins and
didn't have critical injuries yeah and
the Falcons have out continually desam
right but I look at the Saints and go
for them to be three and one right now I
know they're how they always start the
season
now they go from a 10 and 6 to an 11 and
5 12 and 4 right maybe because you three
right because you see all the issues in
Tampa you see all the issues in Atlanta
and their defense and then you go okay
Carolina the Saints always play well
against Carolina Dan this could really
start clicking in any way I know I feel
like I know Carolina yeah I do yeah what
the by yeah even with the by I know
we've all forgotten about them but yes I
think the overall DNA structure of their
team is not going to change it's a new
creative passing offense this year with
norv turner and it's got some old school
running qualities with it along with the
Cam Newton stuff and the defensive
scheme hasn't changed a whole lot
they've got more athletic on the back
end which is gonna help them you don't
know the Packers nope you don't know the
Vikings I didn't we know the Packers
yeah but it's never gonna be pretty in
certain weeks because the offense it's
just not creative enough it's all on 12
to do it we don't know the Vikings know
we don't know the eagle know we don't
know the Giants know we don't know the
Cowboys not really not really we haven't
seen it all together right there's no
yes there's the Seahawks are what they
are they are the Niners are done yeah
agreed
like Philadelphian dows are two teams I
look at to go like first thing I know
what they're going to be yes but they're
not there yet so I'm not gonna like dive
into it I do feel better about my Dallas
NFC East pick yes it start like if Zeke
if they start figure
this out we'll get into those yeah right
but then okay so that's the NFC yeah and
the Lions the Lions we don't know either
no we definitely don't but they're
dangerous they're dangerous and I do
think they're trending in the right
direction do you know the Patriots not
yet no we're still figuring that out I
don't and we have to also see with what
they try to do once Julian Edelman is
back in the fold here definitely don't
with the Josh Gordon gets a little more
comfortable along as well
definitely don't know what the Dolphins
are no we're gonna wait and see neither
for the bills or the Jets right uh the
Ravens I feel like we know we know we
know the Ravens it's it's back to Ravens
football big badass [ __ ] on
defense [ __ ] you we owned a line of
scrimmage
healthy multiples creative things they
can do on that side of the ball the
offense healthy on the o-line downhill
we oh you think you know what run plays
going great we're just bigger than you
we're gonna move you I feel like they
have like six tight ends on their roster
they do they do and I'll do different
speed of receiver so it's a nice little
formula John Brown's a legit one he's a
legit weapons change their team Steelers
do you know I know think we know that's
definitely not we don't know this deal I
don't think we know the Steelers I don't
think we know the Bengals or the Browns
I agree we know Jacksonville okay for
sure the Jack still hasn't changed
they're the same thing we saw last year
we know one of our city one of our
segments was predicting back in June for
the show right predicting how teams
would do yeah and you predicted back in
June the Jaguars would start one in
three leer three and one I went crazy
but I mean everyone know they buy the
Giants Patriots you know yes
but yeah I took a shot in the dark but
they came out there and they're they can
still win what they can still in one so
do you know the Titans do you know the
Texans I don't think so no I don't the
Titans I feel like close to knowing I
just need to see a little bit more of
their offensive structure still I still
think they're still trying to find their
way with the new system on offense
Mariota has been banged up so he hasn't
quite been able to do what he's got to
do but there's a lot of like positive
qualities there and the Colts will be in
every 3227 game for the rest of the year
with Andrew Luck no doubt I love
watching Andrew it is fun rooting first
I'm just telling you right now I'm
picking Jacksonville to beat Kansas City
this weekend just like no doubt in my
mind I don't know what weighs reddish
nope just telling you right now they are
underdog are they really yeah I have
good stats about that I already looked
it up because I got too excited
hey FC West teams do you know any of
them I know the Chiefs yet I don't think
we know the Chiefs yet I feel like I
know the Chiefs I do mmm yeah I do I
didn't want to see a ball controlled
team really make every possession tough
for mahomes that every time that's what
we're gonna get this weekend we are
gonna get that this weekend the only
problem is that of all the ball control
teams like there's not a lot of teams
like that that have the defense that
Jacksonville has to go along with it so
this is like an outlier team they're
playing and I cannot wait for this game
it's gonna be amazing
holy cow but Broncos Raiders Charles I
feel comfortable with I do
I think the Broncos the build Musgrave
offense does everything you know their
running game is coming along past
protections a little bit of an issue
with them the defense and we're gonna
get into it again
diva's is good there's no other way
around it and they're being more
creative on what they're doing on the
defensive side of the ball this year I
think the least the team that we know
the least is the Chargers yes we don't
have Bo so we're getting Cory leach it
back this week but the defense has been
a mess the on fences just Philip Rivers
doing whatever the hell he want exactly
let's start there though the Denver
Kansas City game yeah let's just start
before the notes don't even look at your
notes yet patrick mahomes yeah there
were so many plays that I just sat back
and went I don't know if anybody else
can do this the karaoke rolling left
crossbody finding the guy in the middle
of the field the second and 30 plates
and his ability to throw so much force
while running not the biggest fan of
Witten and booger but the entire game
they're going wow wow wow and I'm going
you know that's accurate analysis right
Wow
yes um just I want to hear Sims talk
about him Holmes I mean he's the second
best quarterback in the NFL that's the
first thing we're gonna say it's
official it's for games I know it's not
a huge sample size and I certainly don't
like anointing anybody that high but
it's undeniable I've seen enough with
you know as you've heard me say before
numbers don't mean anything to me I mean
of course they're taken to account but
the big thing is okay every quarterback
in the NFL can do
about complete the 20-yard pass to the
receiver that's wide open whoa
whoop-dee-doo great he's wide open and
you could throw it twenty yards over the
middle for twenty million a year whoa
you're special no what makes guy special
is when there's nothing there
when there's nothing and then they're
still making unbelievable plays and oh
my gosh then there's nothing there and
you're under pressure and then you go he
still made an unbelievable play that's
when I go holy crap we're seeing the
rebirth of Aaron Rodgers in a red jersey
wearing 15 who do you compare them to
because I made a joke on Twitter that he
that when John Elway sees him he's like
oh it's my twin like it's that it's
along that line here's what's really
funny the reason I asked away when I
watch Baker may feel yeah
the announcers go he reminds me of brett
farr right when I watch Patrick mahomes
the announcers go he reminds me of Brett
Favre Baker Mayfield in my home's are
not the same guy everybody the I feel
like the Baker Mayfield Brett Favre
thing was stolen from me too I just
would like to say that I said on a bunch
of radio things and I feel like
everybody's taking that but I also did
take this for the draft where he sat on
the belly Brett Favre pictures so but he
doesn't you but he does have that he
would be that would be the guy here we
might assume that Laura Baker is Brett
Favre's personality and Patrick mahomes
is Brett Favre's talent mmm he's more
talented than Brett Favre whoa yeah whoa
yeah whoa I know so you go from saying
he has Brett Favre level Talent yeah do
he has more talent than Brett Farr I
think so yeah yeah I mean yeah I mean
the thing that's weird for me I love to
compare quarterbacks you know that and I
love it
mahomes throwing motion is a little
different than anybody's his arm is just
so flexible and the positions the the
karaoke throw across the field we know
that's amazing but what's more amazing
is just how easy and effortless it is
like I sit there and rewind throws and
I'm just like I don't get it
how does he throw this this hard like
this it's amazing and there's just so
many of those throws every week I think
that's what's amazing so
yeah it's it's a talent of a Favre
Rodgers Elway that we just go holy cow
like I've never seen this before
it's that kind of I poppin thing and
he's he more talented than Rodgers he's
got a little bit I think even thinking
about yeah yeah I am I think I think
this I would say he is a more talented
down the field thrower his ability to
just flick a ball 50 yards or 40 yards
on the run might be a hair better than
Rodgers but is able the ability to just
quick flick it like Rodgers can that's
where Rogers would get him but the
running and elusive you know what about
mobility who's like mobile I think
Rogers is quicker I don't know if he's
faster hmm right mahomes when he decides
to tuck it and run like you saw on the
touchdown run even on the touchdown run
I don't think we got fools I don't think
on we haven't seen mahomes run and dive
yet yeah right right I've seen my home's
like pick it up and then go I got it
yeah I'm touchdown yes but I mean I just
look at things like Darian Stuart's
chasing him and he doesn't gain one
ground we saw we don't saw Denver and
actually before we get into this I
actually thought it was funny
mahomes threw it Lefty and everybody was
going crazy right and that's how there's
no left-handed quarterbacks in the NFL
and the fact that it's automatic lefties
the off hand yeah it's just funny to me
it is amazing it's start I mean that
that's come on that's such a special
play I want to just get into the notes
because it was so unbelievable that game
I don't even know what to say
before we get into the note yeah talk
about wanting to say I want to play
something for you okay
this is the other side of mahomes that
is being talked about a lot okay talking
to Kermit the Frog yeah if I can get
some audio excuse me this is a song okay
let's can you do Patrick mahomes voice
imitation that great team around me and
just having a go there have fun and then
I got guys around me that are good and
you know I just I'm just playing ball
and Andy's calling plays and I like it
the coaches guys I have around me with
the coaches and I like to throw the depo
and it's so much fun
he's such like a handsome cute kid it's
just so funny to hear him say that I
mean I do like the fact though that he's
like yeah anytime the team wants to
ground me and then they say they imitate
his voice that Andy does the best
imitation that's great it just also
before we get into the notes yeah I want
to give credit to Andy Reid hmm because
as an Eagles fan at the end of that era
we were really tired of that guy and
he's clearly proven what an amazing
coach he is yeah but I'm watching him on
the sidelines and Erik be enemy is not
calling the plays he's literally just
the guy repeating what Andy says into
the microphone right but mahomes is
going through it he's struggling you
know what I mean and there's Andy
sitting next to him on the bench and
I've never seen that demeanor from a
coach before I've never seen one a head
coach sitting there next to the
quarterback I've never seen that before
right and - he wasn't even like looking
at him they're not like holding up like
Andy's just kind of sitting there with
his hands on his lap kind of looking off
to the side tonight
Haidee doing yeah and that man you can
see the connection to the way Pat talks
about Andy - like I don't know like have
you ever had a head coach doing that no
not quite like that no yeah he wasn't as
he wasn't as empowering to the
quarterback as Andy is Andy makes his
quarterback feel confident and like
they're awesome which is that what I
love about Andy do you think it's
because he was Favre's quarterback coach
back in the day that like if you could
be Favre's guy you could be anybody yes
to a degree yes and he's he's able to
handle that type of strong personality
that like okay Brett might say something
crazy and throw a stupid pass but I can
deal with it because there's 99 other
awesome ones that go along with it and
not everybody can do that like Gruden
might be I call that one play oh I gotta
get a new quarterback let me sign seven
more yeah cuz he messed up that one play
but brian has that perfect personality
he has the perfect personality to just
instill the confidence even just think
about your Eagles days those years when
Donovan was struggling and yet he never
panicked all right he never made Donovan
feel like he was the issue even though
we were all like damn Donovan can't hit
a 10 yard pass you know he hits the
screen
the 80 yard bomb but he can't anything
in between but he never wavers he's the
ultimate supporter of his hires he
really always takes the bullet for them
if they lose a football game and that is
known and yeah I think he's just sitting
over there from the homes like just to
make him feel comfortable like hey you
know I hate when you do this on third
down think of this and he's just sitting
there and I think he's also just trying
to get a feel like he's sitting there
next to him is he rattled right now he's
probably listening in one ear yes he
rattled is he a little panicked okay
he's not let me get up and go coach the
team here are your notes what you wrote
about Patrick mahomes
yeah you wrote I'm just gonna read them
yeah mahomes is so good it's amazing
only the physically elite could have won
this game went Rodgers Wilson and then
you thought about it and you wrote
really maybe just mahomes and Rogers
yeah yeah because I think some of the
throws he made with people around him on
his legs about to get sacked full speed
running and the 30 yard throw one second
and 30 I was like a 35 yard throw as
he's going backwards and on a full speed
like whence you know I love Wentz and I
love Russell Wilson but I don't think
they can throw like that I just has an
Eagles fan
remember the Seahawks throw yes it was
amazing Mahone's arm is clearly stronger
than when Holmes arm is clearly one of
the three strongest in the history of
the NFL yeah it's already got to that
level you also wrote a third down almost
all conversions third down almost all
conversions are mahomes making it
happened by himself which is the sign of
a great QB yeah which is another thing
that we see out of Rodgers and whence
yes yes exactly right is it the play
doesn't have to be perfect and in this
game Denver their defensive game plan
was on point it was perfect the things
they did it was extremely creative they
weren't gonna let the deep balls beat
them they did a lot of different things
in the line of scrimmage where they
didn't blitz but it looked like it was
blitz you know how we call that blitz
change stuff where two guys might come
but to drop out it's still only four men
rushing it fooled them a few times
amazed about his ability I'm about to
get sacked and kind of still throw it to
someone where I might give you a chance
Kelsey you're really covered but I'm
about to get sacked and I'll put it
outside maybe you make a great catch if
not it's gonna be incomplete he does
that stuff really good did they key on
Kelsey because it seemed like the first
three quarters the frustration level of
Kelsey whether it was balls behind him
or just like he always had people around
yeah he just missed some throws to
Kelsey and yeah they were in too tight
quarters where I think they fooled
mahomes a little bit of few times where
he thought he was just gonna have these
easy completions and the Holmes missed a
few throws in the game that I don't
think he's missed in the first three
weeks where yeah I mean he must confused
that was rattled to mahomes that was
that's rattled from a home you said this
and I think this sums it up perfect yeah
scary thing is mahomes leaves three or
four big plays in the field every week
he struggled and the offense had 446
yards yes it's that's that's I guess
you're right that's the scary thing it's
amazing I mean there has been every week
and I talk about this my dad and I know
he's not gonna be able to come home with
us today but we talked about how you
know it's amazing what he's doing but we
laugh and go like man there was like
three or four plays there where I think
he's like making a conscious effort to
not be too crazy right he's I'm not
gonna throw interceptions I'm not gonna
hurt our team to where there was even a
few one-on-one chances the other night
with Tyree killed they took a chance in
blitz out of nowhere and it's Tyreke on
Pac Man and he is gone I mean gone but
he doesn't give it a look cuz he just
didn't feel right in the pocket so he
tried to scramble out and throw it away
or whatever it may be
shoutout to Pac Man yeah like our guy
who gets signed like critical point of
the game sweep to Tyree kill Oh hack man
runs him down yes that was it I was like
damn man like we're never gonna really
appreciate the athletic freak that
pac-man was no you're right and well I
mean to appreciate it is it's what is
what your is this for pac-man 12
something and he's still a starting
man-to-man corner in the NFL I mean
that's really all you guys if you didn't
get signed before that right you also
wrote this down need you to explain yeah
you can tell Kansas
city knows how special mahomes is you
know me I'm watching the sidelines
things like that he's making throws and
if the sidelines in the view from any of
them I'd look over to see what they're
doing they're all like and they're
looking at each other anything pointing
at him like you the man you made it have
that was you and then you know I see
guys on the sidelines like when he
throws the left hand and throw guys on
the side and look at each other look at
Scott's amazing I mean so it's things
like that that's what we saw from Carson
Wentz last year same kind of thing where
you could tell the team is like on a
daily basis seeing the amazing thing the
guy does and then it comes over to the
game and they're still amazed that's
when you know you have something really
special in your hands you also wrote
they need Sammy Watkins they do need
Sammy Watkins they need that because
Chris Conley wasn't breaking any tackles
but was he playing the Sammy Watkins
role when he yeah him and the kid
Robinson number 11 notch and hey this
this team's gonna have to win through
their offense we know that oh yeah they
need that other weapon you mean Sammy
Watkins could be an injury or like Draya
shot girl
I mean shocker I saw him pull his hammy
does he was running a crossing route in
the first quarter and he kind of gimped
a little bit no they go gosh here it
goes
and then he was out a few plays later
but yet they do need him they do for the
way they want to play and win football
games they're not going to be able to
depend on their defense as you know and
it's that's no secret they need that
extra weapon so people can't just focus
in on Tyreke and Travis Kelce that third
weapon is crucial in a really great
offense like we've seen with the Rams or
some other great offenses you wrote down
that the Denver this is about now now we
saw one team have a little success
against mahomes yeah and you wrote that
the game plan was pretty perfect
they didn't blitz but when they did it
was a zone blitz with soft coverage they
talked about leaving people out and kind
of playing it back yeah first down they
played coverage yeah had three big guys
on the line with Vaughn there so they
kept sized to just and I mean Kareem
hunt kind of got off he did but on first
down they just put big people on the
field yeah and there you could tell
their focus was to neutralize the
downfield passing game so my question
for you is you wrote teams are gonna
play
Kansas City the way Denver did unless
Reid stays patient with the run and then
they add more creative quick short
passes yes how many teams the NFL can do
what Denver did how many of them have
that personnel that's the proper
question and then you're right and
there's not a lot so when I say a
comment like that I'm really thinking
about like okay playoff elite team type
football the Jacksonville is the Raven
right exactly right any of those teams
that New England will try to play that
way if they ended up matching them in
the playoffs I know it's not an elite
talent whatever it may be but that's who
I'm really talking about more than
anything yes is is going to be the
Denver or showed if you have talent and
you have a good front for that this is
the way to go to at least give yourself
a chance a fighting chance and hey they
don't win that game unless he makes four
or five just unreal plays so yeah I
think going forward they have to add
more of a repertoire Andy Reid if we're
gonna say one negative about him
throughout this whole career he's never
been patient enough with the run I do
think he has to continue to be really he
really does it's gonna help mahomes and
Tyreke and Kelly was phenomenal
phenomenal and the short passing game it
took him a while to realize okay we're
not gonna get any deep passes he really
didn't adjust to it to like late in the
third quarter and then he finally
started going alright I guess we got the
car shore passes we're just not gonna
get deep on them tonight and it started
being Bam Bam Bam and then it was okay
it's third down good down field
oh I gotta make a play wham hit another
play but yeah I think that was what
that'll be the approach you see like
nobody's just gonna get up in the face
of this team because you're just you're
you're dancing with the devil in the
pale moonlight on that one like that you
thought that the hook-and-ladder if it
could have gotten to Emanuel Sanders was
going to be a touchdown it's gonna be
really close the one thing I didn't
understand is people on TV and I think
we text each other that night they were
like I mean they're gonna run out of
time I wanted to be like they're three
feet from the sidelines if he's gonna
get knocked out of bounds or he's gonna
turn the corner and run the touchdown
and they're gonna know the run and I
thought Hall was fantastic it was a
great call it really was it was a nice
play by Steven Nelson to get his hands
in there as he was trying to make the
pitch and he mess it up I mean we could
watch it together
no I saw because I have a manual Sanders
of my Finn okay I can show you the
coaches syllabus I was gonna say to
where you could actually see it you'd go
oh man maybe he would have turned the
corner there keenum had Demaryius Thomas
on that play yeah I'm gonna play before
oh yeah those two Mary's Thomas's fault
talk about it I thought I go he looked
really unathletic trying to get first of
all he gave up on the race load down and
then when he realized Keenan was looking
at him he tried to restart again if he
just ran from the start he would have
had him I mean that would have been
incompletion Demaryius Thomas don't let
down how they let - how did he fall off
so quickly I I you know last year it
wasn't the same guy like wasn't the same
last year injury he's had two knee
issues he's had to deal with before he
signed that like 8-year 88 million
dollar deal yeah it was a little after
that the knee issues yeah but I think he
has a little of the and I don't want to
speculate but I've you know i think it's
he's managing this knee situation all
the time like it's always a bother and
practice things like that but yes he's
lost his explosion and as we said two
weeks ago to me the cuttin kid is the
number two receiver on that football
team they would break why they go to him
I mean he just needs to get there like I
thought it was a good thing by Witten
where you're like dude when you're in
the red zone you're huge
yeah rip your hand out and get the ball
right like he had a few of those moments
for the other ones where it was like
he's taken this ball away from exactly
right really special yes you think they
need it you think they need Eric Berry
back oh my god d4 looks really good but
the Chiefs we know what they are they're
gonna try it out score yeah 35 to 31 and
that the balls in mahomes hand and
they're dangerous yes they're dangerous
d forward I know he hurt his groin in
that game right a little bit
yeah that's big they need him cuz he
gives great yeah and they're gonna and
again they're third down defense was
amazing again that's it if Kansas City
can get the third down there are a
handful then because the d4 - Justin
Houston and our guy Chris Jones they can
all pin their ears back in Gulf and they
can do things by themselves they're just
it's a defense that lacks details and
certain coverages and things it's the
little minut details that end up really
killing them and I'm not gonna go into a
long story about the other whether it's
jamming slot receivers whether it's
seeing a guy coming in motion on the
tight end on the defensive end and the
defense ends got to know Dan they might
crack me down and throw the talk and
toss
we pit out there No so get some leverage
on the guy except the edge it's little
things like that that I always see from
Kansas City they need Eric Barry for one
reason and you know what that is because
in number 22 Orlando Scandrick is the
biggest liability on their football team
and the Denver Broncos do it and any
time they saw man-to-man they said were
throw-in 222 saw the pass interference
I mean exactly right late I mean he was
like a 1 host 1 horse-riding slay I mean
he'd held the guy the whole time he just
saying I'm gonna hold and then they're
gonna throw the flag and I look back and
go I can't believe they called it I'm so
sick of that crap from DB's right now I
cannot take it
Leyton p.i complaining what's it's it's
like worse than NBA crap right there it
really bothers me right now
it really does because fans at home are
only seeing their reaction they're like
how could they call that this game's
rigged well I will say this that I don't
really care what fans at home are saying
because they're the ones that are
arguing with me about Peyton Manning
excuse me Eli Manning being done yeah
let's move to that okay Eli Manning here
are the notes that you have on Eli and I
want to get through them because you're
Saints notes are interesting second
quarter misses wide open Odell won't
step up sterling Shepherd middle post
uncovered those can't be missed
Eli can't make power throws wide
receivers are clearly frustrated on film
Eli doesn't give them a chance to catch
it or doesn't throw it when it's
one-on-one won't let a play develop
third quarter Eli has been pressured on
just one play let's start there we know
the receivers are frustrated
we know that Eli can't throw the ball we
know he's missing open throws but
everyone including myself on Monday says
well he's under pressure yeah you say in
your notes that he's been under pressure
and only one play in the third at this
point in the third Krait yeah and in the
fourth quarter in the second play was
the first time that his protection was
hard right there's a few plays in the
fourth quarter where it got tough but
they were down so explain this to me
everyone out there is telling me that
Eli's not done his protection stinks
what are you seeing on the Phil
all right listen it's protections not
great the start of that game the first
half of that game the first two and a
half quarters into the third quarter
there drew brees was under more pressure
than Eli Manning he just want everybody
to know that we could see can come over
to bleacher report well I'll watch the
film together and I'll show you
but Giroux breeze moved in the pocket
and then completed a pass and you forget
he was under pressure because he
completed the pass so we just go huh
good play or there or he just stands
there and makes the throw downfield he's
getting hit and then we forget there was
pressure we just go good play but Eli
does none of that so then we just go oh
the pressure so I think that's part of
the Jedi mind trick people are seeing
but yes as their moments of pressure
certainly but there's no movement in the
pocket
there's no guts to stand there in the
pocket and make throws when people are
open it's all about protecting numbers
and protecting himself that's all I can
really say about it there's moments it
this week went beyond the frustration of
the receivers you could really see it on
the coaches film you could see when the
plays were over the receivers dropped on
their head and just walking off the
sideline or looking back and like wait
you already threw it I'm wide open
you've already checked it down I'm here
nobody's around me I were just looking
at him shaking their hand or or odell
with the ball that went way over his
head before the first happened and yeah
yeah he was yelling at Eli he was like
how did you I couldn't even touch that
I'm the greatest athlete in the planet
right now and I couldn't jump up I have
a 40 inch vertical and I couldn't jump
up and touch that ball yes it's um I
know the protections been the issue for
the New York Giants but I would tell you
that I don't understand why why does
nobody give sam donald that benefit here
in the knee or in New York Arian Sam
Donald was under attack in Jacksonville
last week nobody seems to care about
that Russell Wilson's been under attack
for four years better but but guys like
Russell Wilson this year deshaun Watson
yeah who else is it gonna say Sam Donald
on Sunday I mean their protection has
been worse this year than Eli Manning's
but nobody cares about them every we
just saw what's wrong with Russell
Wilson what's wrong with them I don't
get it and I don't know it's driving me
crazy I'm a Giants fan
I like the giant yeah I know people
think I'm being an Eli Manning hater I
don't care philosophically or
psychologically why do you think this is
I why are we why do great memories
two-month-long great memories and then
they beat the Patriots but but I get
that and I know that we live in
nostalgia but when something is clear
and I guess what you're saying is what
is it because he looks helpless when he
gets sacked and that we feel bad for I
think there's part of that too yes
and that Russell kind of runs around and
we think that maybe he runs too much and
he may be exactly right or yet people
are just like well he's fast it doesn't
matter he can kid he should be able to
run away like I don't really understand
the expectation of all I wrote under a
bleacher report post about Odell
complaining I said Eli Manning is 37
years old and I put a grandpa emoji and
a lot of the responses were but Tom
Brady's 40 and Drew Brees is 39 I just
want to ask everyone to do a quick
little thought process here what do we
know about Tom Brady his diet is so
crazy he doesn't eat strawberries and he
trains like a madman drew brees can
still probably squat like 400 pounds and
is like Affleck has always been a leader
and and did a spin move for a touchdown
last week in Atlanta Eli Manning taking
on two linebackers and spinning Eli
Manning we see a beach photo and we
laugh and then we wonder why he's a
victim in the pocket because like Eli
Manning hasn't kept himself in the shape
of those guys definitely now he just has
it no like 37 and 39 are not created
equal
no they're just not like if you're
working out all the time and you're not
eating everything like you're gonna be
in great shape and you're gonna be
physically confident right Eli is not
confident he's not physically impressive
his arms not there is there any chance
that this flips because you even wrote
in here that pat Shermer you're
expecting he's putting in short throws I
do because he knows that Eli won't throw
the deep one that meant me reading tea
leaves of how a play caller calls and
calls the game yeah I think he had a
moment of
falling just short passes cuz he was
like I give up he's not gonna throw it
so I'm just gonna call dink and dunk and
that's what it went and then you know
like I said at the end of the day
everyone's gonna look at it and go huh
31 a 41 for 255 and a touchdown and a
few weeks Aires ago he didn't really
play that bad in that Saints game okay
he got about a hundred yards in the last
two drives of the game when the game was
over okay and I don't just don't know
what to say like in those scenarios you
know again people are gonna go oh okay
the protections not great in the fourth
quarter and things like that yeah their
protections not great in the fourth
quarter because he's dug them into a
hole to where they have to throw and now
the defense just goes we're just gonna
rush the passer we don't have to worry
about anything else anymore so now he's
under pressure in the fourth quarter but
it's because of what he did in the first
three quarters I think that's what
people are missing on that conversation
there too I think the killer thing is -
you mentioned the Giants D has been good
it's been creative yeah four red zone
trips and they held the Saints to four
field goals it's amazing
you know and then and then your offense
it's you wrote you it's 26 to 10 and
it's your fault
Eli yeah that's what you wrote I know
Saints offense though is starting to
click and you said three things Sean
Payton number one
Taysom Hill yeah you wrote Taysom Hill
as a thing this Wildcat package I just
want to remind everybody what Joe
Lombardi said about Taysom Hill this
offseason you see Aaron Rodgers and
those kind of guys make plays that way
they're the ability to avoid the rush
this guy runs a sub for 540 and he's
strong he might be the strongest guy on
the team I went and looked up more
articles Taysom Hill can do a squat of
625 what can you do a squat of in my
prime like in my prime I was probably
gosh I don't think I ever put more than
375 on my back
625 I for a quarterback yeah he can do a
front squat he did this at college right
what tell me before I even say the
number like what's a front squat explain
why that's hard I mean a front squat
would be putting the huge bar
wait on the top and your front
underneath your chin across your
shoulder in collarbone and how hard is
that what's just explain it it's insane
because not only are you you're sitting
back when you have to have the core
strength to be able to balance all that
weight on the front so what's a lot o
men really anything over 200 pounds is a
lot and I'm guessing he did 400 at
college he did 430 yeah in college
Michael Thomas called him a created
player like that you beyond matter right
so why was this one of the one things
for Sean Payton it's just another thing
he's doing to give them an edge it's
just another thing you play the Saints
and you go damn they got all these
formations this awesome run game drew
Brees in the past game and then sit back
there with Taysom Hill what's doing an
option with chimera exactly so if you
like chimera is one of the scariest
players in the NFL and the Falcons learn
last week you got to worry about Taysom
Hill 250 yard run in the clutch yes did
it against the Giants big-time run he's
a man crush on I'm Sean Payton has a man
crush on Jason I know this yes he has a
man crush on him this is his like his
boy I've heard people in his inner
circle make fun of him like well he's
intrigued by the dream boyfriend right
he's intrigued by and I heard the
comment he's made as he Steve Young on
steroids like not actually on steroids
but basically went to BYU right right so
that's what he's basically saying is and
if you remember really Steve Young
couldn't throw the ball very good coming
out of college like that was an issue
the 49ers had to really work with him
and I I think that Sean Payton sees
maybe a little piece of that that like
maybe this guy could be the guy in a few
years but that's why Sean Payton so
special that's why he's a man you also
wrote passing out of endzone at the end
of the game right passing out of the
endzone at the end of the game I think
it was 26 to 18 right the Giants make
that touchdown drive finally and you go
okay the Johnny's got a little momento
beer Ted Ginn drops the kickoff return
remember I think it's the Pens back Sean
didn't do the old all I'm gonna give it
up the middle just to give us a little
more room no he came out aggressive and
got out of the got out and changed field
position with two throws right away
those are things that great coaches do
to go we are going to attack you just
cuz you pinned us back doesn't mean
we're gonna sit here and then punt from
our own endzone and give these the ball
at the 50-yard he's going down swinging
and that's what I love about Sean Payton
you also wrote fake punt fake punt will
taste some he'll to start the game
they're down seven nothing their first
drive goes three and out he goes you
know what I'm not gonna give them the
ball again right away I'm gonna call the
fake punt he's gonna roll to the right
throw a fade stop to the guy out in the
right the guy this Garrett the gunner
the guy that's covering the gunner he's
not expecting that to happen first down
they go down kick if you get a field
goal in that Drive it's little things
like that that changed the the structure
of the game and we forget about it at
the end of the day sometimes so that's
what the Phil that's what's cool about
film you thought that the Saints
offensive line looks healthy like you
can dominate again and it really seems
like the Saints overall are clicking
they finally played some zone defense
according to your film did they got some
big guys up front like this rookie
Taylor stallworth ended up stopping the
run yeah reading your notes and knowing
how you write you believe that the
Saints are about to start clicking hard
I do yeah they just went on a three-game
winning streak hey you think they're
really gonna be backing hard yes I think
that they're there now have sir sighs I
think that Monday night's game against
Washington is gonna be really close yeah
I'm sure it will be because Washington
went in there and almost beat the crap
out of Al and right Washington matches
up with that man yeah I get that and it
will not be easy but even whether they
win or lose I still think the Saints are
on the right path right now
you wrote this you wrote a note and it
felt like a note to yourself if this is
so yeah if I were a coach in the NFL I
would have speed in the back seven of my
defense with one or two big linebackers
on the roster but my deal would be huge
[ __ ] yeah I think that is the future
yeah what made you write that I just
think I'm thinking about this offensive
explosion we're having in the NFL right
now right I mean we've had more 400 yard
passers this year through four weeks and
we did all of last year total that's a
points explosion right now the game the
the these defensive coordinators we
talked about a little bit on Monday
about the Zimmern and I'll sleep we're
into it yeah I mean you talk about all
that
I just tell them the stat oh well the
stat of that right there the Zimmer and
Seattle scheme as I just thought I
started only look at where the defenses
are ranked and part of this conversation
and my little Theory here well only
three of the Seattle Zimmer schemes are
in the top 16 in football there's ten of
them and the bottom sixteen bottom half
right and the three that are on the top
16 are super talented like we talked
about
it's the Jacksonville Jaguars it's the
Dallas Cowboys now and we'll get to that
note because the Dallas Cowboys are even
more talented and I've been credit for
it and then the Seattle Seahawks and I
would say the Seattle Seahawks are not
super talented but it's still Pete
Carroll this is his original scheme and
what they are and and they haven't
played great offenses so I will see
about them but all the other teams and
the top 16 and defense have you go
through it the Baltimore Ravens Dean
Pease ish multiple coverage game plan
coverage Washington Redskins Manaus Keys
from Baltimore right so he's Monday but
well yeah when you saw the Saints
okay so sorry yes break down what you
why you this is the future of defense
how is that it really didn't have
anything to do with the Saints more than
my overarching thought and as I was
watching that game going like this
offensive pass explosion of football I
really think the next thing defenses are
gonna have to do is go
we got to play coverage more this is a
new league in the NFL teams aren't
trying to like beat their head into
running the ball 25 30 times a game and
if they are running the ball that time
that many times the game ever team is
rolling the ball 30 times a game other
than like the Dallas Cowboys and a few
other teams Seattle's trying to do right
but the rest of them if there are
running 30 times a game like I'm gonna
say 15 of them are like a speed sweep
and you know toss crack it's not like
traditional downhill running right so I
think at some point here in the NFL a
team which is a little bit New England
has done and we've talked about this a
lot with their bare front yeah you know
what I do think that's gonna have to be
the future you're gonna have to go like
I said Denver did to start the game
Denver put they put dome atop echo
Shelby Harris and who was the other guy
they put a deep
said derec wolf so basically like 310
305 and 290 with a bond mailer wolf is
one of the scariest looking football
players in the NFL right I mean crazy
white dudes they're always scared he's
also like that six five but like
wonderfully proportion I know like
peco's got like the big belly and the
big hair I Scott
but wolf was just like I'm big
everywhere they are the scary wasn't
always the guys that I was worried we're
gonna hurt me to take a higher band and
Brice I was always worried like he's
psycho and he actually might gonna like
my leg like he might be like ah I heard
it break
that's about those guys but yeah I just
think that could be the future of like
if I'm thinking about football right now
I would really be trying to collect
really big people up front and go damn
its second and ten the team could run
the ball here okay but most likely this
day and age you're gonna throw it I'd
like to have at least three 300 pounders
on that front line and then PI two
safeties deep and go okay I got three
300 pounders in one good pass rusher and
let's see if you can run it on then
before we get to Dallas cuz you got to
preview that do you want to clarify your
Philadelphia Eagles defensive commentary
from Monday oh yes
talking about two safeties and playing
more of a standard defense the big thing
and I'm mad I missed this on Monday the
the the Philadelphia Eagles their
biggest issue is their deal that's is
good and Schwartz does good things like
there's things where I just come in that
was nice that was creative I like it you
know I don't know what Cory Graham was
doing on that last like fourth down
where they got the out route out he's
the outside corner in that one I don't
know he went inside and let somebody out
leverage you my guy that maybe he just
messed up but for the rest of the game
and really through your year here the
big plays come when you guys go
aggressive first play of the Tampa Bay
game corner blitz Oh now as to Sean
Jackson on Malcolm Jenkins like yeah
it's not gonna have like so you you said
that when they just sit back and they
let their front four go and they play
coverage they're unbelievable they're
really AM it's hard to move the ball in
them so are they getting pressure and
like like are they not getting pressure
so they need to blitz which is leading
all this that's what I don't because all
I'm hearing when is going hot stuff
right as people
saying that the front four is not
generating enough pressure that Michael
Bennett Haloti Ngata
are too old that Fletcher Cox needs help
and that they need Timmy Jernigan to get
back that's what your boy Mike Lombardi
said on his podcast and you're shaking
your head and I don't agree with that no
I know that he didn't watch the film
because his was going off TV tape right
so what did you say yeah no I don't
think pressure has been one bit of issue
the only game I could say maybe pressure
was an issue this season was the Tampa
Bay game where I said damn yeah Tampa
Bay we talked about it there big ol line
they hung in there with Philadelphia
they did not let your deep that D line
ruin the game it's not old halona Dada's
not oh it had some plays in the game the
other day where I was like damn who is
that well that was Bennet holy crap he
got through their issues right now are
the blitzing the blitzing and you like I
don't know Schwartz can change that I
don't know if she can either I really
hope he can and the other thing I would
say too is they might be time to go
Jalen Mills in the slot Sydney Jones
outside so they Jones as an outside
corner he's long as he's growing on you
cuz you doubted him in the priest I did
I didn't think he was totally 100
percent I didn't know if he'd be able to
do it I think you're better off putting
him outside and putting jaylen Mills
inside what is it about Jalen Mills he's
just not as gifted as the Eagles think
he is did they leave him in some of the
situation's he's left in it's just it
would go back bad ball skills it's not
necessarily bad ball skills he just
doesn't have elite speed he gets burned
he just gets outrun and he you know you
put him on an island too many times you
know the code gets cracked eventually
and they do you have like the best run
defense in the NFL yes because your D
line they create havoc there so all that
stuff is fake news I think so yes I I
feel very confident about that they've
had one game where I've said the pass
rusher wasn't what I expected to be it
was like the 97° game and Tampa Bay
right I mean it's it's pretty good the
pressure you lost the Tampa and then who
was the week after that Who am I missing
who was the next win Holtz Oh Colt
pressure was phenomenal yeah it's funny
like I'm at a point now and I don't
think it's because the Eagles won the
Super Bowl but I look at these teams and
the teams that are freaking out right
now yeah or the fan bases are there's no
need to know like when you if you're
that to and
- you're fine yes like the Chargers fans
I would be freaking out right now but
the same point like all right I'm - and
- yeah and we're getting Bo so back
we're getting all these guys it just
makes me think all right Dallas this is
the team that we had winning the NFC
East taking on Detroit you wrote Dallas
offense they're finally making Zeke the
focal point of everything 12 touches in
the first half 10 rushes that's good for
the second half and the Cowboys defense
is they're running yet it's yeah it's
good for the second half
glutamate which I mean is the beauty of
Zeke is he wears on you
they get in a groove as they go just
like anything I mean just like doing
more of hosting you go I'm getting
better at this well when you get 10 runs
in the first half and the offensive line
gets to put the pulling guard gets to
pull a handful of times you start to go
ok I get a good feel for their
linebackers in their speed and you know
how their guards have their defensive
tackles take on blocks so you get a feel
for that in the game instead of where I
would say the first three weeks would be
one of those plays and then they
wouldn't revisit it for another 15 plays
hard to get in a fold that way so yes
they said we are gonna come out and
establish the run and they lack weapons
on offense everywhere everywhere so it's
feeling more and more likely that Dez is
gonna resign it does seem that way right
every every TV show I turn on they're
talking about Dez going back to Dallas
I'm seeing Dez at concerts with Jerry
Jones and they need them they do need
him I don't know if he's gonna
necessarily be that big of a help the
only thing he can do that these other
guys can't do is exactly right it's
really all they need they need something
something but there's Jeff Swain
teammate the guy no I'm in chief no no
you're right I mean Michael Gallup he
has moments you go okay looks pretty
good Beasley that's in the slot you
wrote Dallas wide receivers can't can
open screens contested throws and you
wrote you like Zeke though in the empty
slot I love it but he's their only
weapon he is their only weapon but are
they running dak no they did not run
them enough last week for me I just feel
like they need to almost really work the
read option I agree it has to be like
beast mode Russell Wilson early years
that's what they should be doing so you
um and you said that quarterbacks you
could see it changing in a few years
where more teams go at the rookie
quarterback instead of paying these guys
a lot when their deals are right
Dax contract is gonna come up a year
before Wentz and a year before Goff
because he was a fourth round pick and
they were first round things right one I
don't know what they're gonna do I don't
know either
cuz what what are you seeing on the game
film of him right now
well the throwing is not phenomenal he
doesn't have a lot of help as we just
talked about the receivers are not great
the offensive scheme is not great he's
not he's still yeah his throwing is not
even as good as it was his rookie year
right now where I just feel like his
motions jeez you know a little bit of
this over-the-top motion at times where
the ball just Rockets down on them and
that bothers me a little nothing I'm my
concern there's still a lot of good
there but I mean part of the skill set
is that he's a big strong athletic guy
and that's my question
yeah when you have a quarterback that's
the face of the franchise whether it's a
carson wentz or an Andrew Luck can you
learn the hard way or it's the Cam
Newton's the DeSean Watson's and you
kind of go hey run but make sure you get
out of bounds and be safe yeah but if
they don't think Dax the guy why not run
them I agreed like if you like and this
sounds so awful coming from the players
podcast but this is what coaches do and
we're trying to win games and it's game
planning and it sounds awful right but
if Dax not the answer right let's get
the six yards right I mean I think it's
slightly less welcome back Le'Veon Bell
feels like they're gonna just use me for
this year and they gave me 500 touches
and they go go ahead be a free agent I'm
just surprised they're not gonna go hey
dak we're gonna run you a lot because
then at least because the the the holes
for Zeke are gonna get six inches bigger
a foot bigger and if it's a real threat
like when I see teams like eyes watch
the Cardinals game earlier in the year
and they did a read option with Sam
Bradford and I said did you really think
that they were gonna think that he was
gonna run but if dak runs even if he
keeps it two times in the first quarter
the rest of the game you're thinking
about it yes yeah you're always have to
worry about it and the way defensive
coordinators are they're like
I'm not gonna be beat by that so I'm
gonna always keep this guy in the back
side for dak Prescott and that's gonna
make passing looks easier that's what
people miss with Russell Wilson early on
in the Seattle career people want to
know why he was so great because
everybody was afraid of the reaction so
they played these really simple defenses
just go we're all in our gaps yeah
they're not gonna burn us with that but
yes and also out of the quarterbacks
you're talking about running
quarterbacks just from pure physical
strength power specimen and you tell me
if I'm wrong
I mean it's Cam Newton and then dak
Prescott like if you ask me a court a
fight broke out with quarterbacks and
the in the bar I don't know Patrick
balls like cuz I don't know where I'd be
true
am I missing anybody there I mean yeah
you'd hundred percent are I know but I
just think those two just as far as pure
power strength body structure aren't I
know Big Ben's a big guy but I'm talking
about like he's this is a rare breed of
a man he's the largest quarterback that
I've been around right I mean other than
Cam Newton he's he's a Josh Allen okay
sure similar looks like that too and I
would just say you know that this is a
dak Prescott he could take a little bit
more punishment than the normal
quarterback he can just like Cam Newton
there they're freaks of nature that way
that's part of their gift so don't be
afraid to run to them but the big thing
is with Dallas just keep featuring the
big guy 21 feature him feature him
feature him it's only going to help the
rest of the team out it's like we talked
about like with New England and Gronk
when they're rolling they just they're
moving Gronk all around and you start
going damn we wanted to double them here
we're gonna do we got to worry about
Gronk we got to worry about Gronk oh
damn it's a good matchup for Julian
Edelman first down damnit you were very
complimentary of the Dallas tee they get
David Irving back eath holy crap yeah
and you wrote a woozi a and Byron Jones
are phenomenal but not a man corners
phenomenal so the D lines gonna be crazy
oh yeah what did you think of the Dallas
D without Sean Lee they miss him how was
Layton Vanda rushed in Jaylon Smith
Jalen was solid Vander rushes athletic
and you notice he's out there because it
was out I still have the same concern of
bender
vander Esch does not want to hit anybody
that's my big thing that's really where
it becomes an issue and that's was my
issue with him in college I just don't
see the physicality of Shawn Lee or some
of the other good middle linebackers and
that's I'm gonna continue to question
that until I really see her but you like
their defense I love their defense their
defense does a few little creative
things coverage wise in a week-to-week
basis for ago that was kind of cool but
those two guys on the outside of woozi a
and Jones they are the real deal and I
know I saw the comments underneath me
saying xav and Howard needs to be in the
top five conversation somebody said oh
he is as tanks great take this up your
ass okay
because I mean it's again it drives me
create people don't think players have
good years and bad years like you said
he was five two years ago why is he
still not five because it's two years
later and he's had three hip contusions
and he pulled his hamstring four times
and he's run nine million Sprint's in
between then so that's why he's not the
same guy like people forget that like I
think these are machines or like this is
Madden video game like the fatigues off
stamin is off why isn't he fast and
awesome forever because it's not a video
game it's real man sorry
yeah but she's all takes work to keep up
with it it does exactly right it's
[ __ ] annoying I can tell you and it
stresses me out but a woozi a and by
Jones week you're looking at a
completely different player yeah just on
the wear and tear this exactly right and
especially when you go through another
season or whatever it may be and they're
special you wrote and this is a thing in
the fantasy community you wrote carry on
Johnson had a great run to start the
game and that was not out there for two
series you wrote Detroit is leaving
yards on the field with the other two
running backs being LeGarrette Blount
right and is it theoretic yeah so you
believe that and and Patricia has come
out and he keeps talking about the
virtue how great it is to have a
committee which he's a hundred percent
taking from Bill it's good to have the
fresh running back the fresh running
back but we've seen this in committees
before when there's one guy that's just
head and shoulders better than the other
two also carry on is not a complete
show-and-tell on what your game plan is
gonna be right when the
blunts on the field you're not passing
when Theo Riddick Sanh the field you're
probably passing right carry-ons the
only one that could do both agreed and I
think what they're missing in the bill
conversation too is bill had weeks yes
it was committee but one week it was
featured Dion Lewis he was the guy we
were going where's lugar blood he rushed
450 yards last week he got to carries
this week so he let that guy go but my
big thing was yes he came out in the
game made a few impressive runs
disappears the next two series they open
up some holes for the other two guys and
they don't maximize it like he does
that's not that's that's what I'm saying
well Garrett to me his beauty is you
know carry on gets the first 15 carries
of the game now he's a little tired
fewer than one third and one let's keep
him in for the next set of first downs
let's let him be a sledgehammer on these
guys you're starting to wear him out
that's the beauty LeGarrette Blount in
this age of his career you don't want
him to be second Drive of the game it's
him one-on-one in space with a
linebacker oh he just got shoestring oh
really he the 250 Brown running back
just got shoestring and didn't get
around the corner I can't talk bad about
LeGarrette hit he's the man I know that
a he's your boy he was amazing yes he is
amazing I mean he's one of my favorites
ever have teammates anybody double Super
Bowl winner yeah alright so let's go now
to well you know what we never really
did we talked about the Rams extensively
in the Vikings because it was a Thursday
night [ __ ] I don't think we did no I
mean yeah I don't think we did I think
we went off on text maybe we talked
about the Anthony bar things yeah I've
watched that offense and I kind of
newsreel the Vikings offense what did
you that's often yeah the Vikings
offense has all the basics like there
have you ever seen a guy like blow by
offensive lineman as easy as Aaron
Donald no like he Mike it's Mike it's
better than Michael Bennett in his our
heart cry steps one way and then taps
them on the back yeah and there it's as
if he's a ghost and they're trying to
hit the ghost but he's invisible yeah
and they go through and they're there's
always an offensive lineman been over
and is it how the [ __ ] does he do it
he's really explosively quick if he gets
his hands on the back of your shoulders
there he ripped you down right away but
really what gets them is he so strong
their base they're bracing for the whole
God he's in her bulrush me and then she
does the jitterbug and then they go whoa
when I'm out of here
and that's why how is endemic in Subin
good okay yes he's been very good yeah
he's a little bit more of their space
eater but the thing I find fascinating
about the Rams is they don't really have
their I almost want to say what they're
talking about a little while ago
they've gone like three big guys up
front for all former first-round picks
Aaron Donald and Dominic ensue Ethan
Westbrook and rockers Jimmy you're doing
some progress right and then Ethan
westbrook's the other smaller rockers is
first good right and then they got a
bunch of speedy linebackers that you
don't really know really good safety in
LaMarcus Joyner up and coming ball hawk
safety and John Johnson the third fact
Lee and the fact that they I mean they
let up a bunch of points without Talib
and Peter's yeah like I didn't think
their defense was abysmal no is that it
visible it's it keeps pressure on you I
think that's the best thing about them
and I think that's the cool thing about
their defensive line is I don't even
know how many sacks they have but they
are in they are around the court they
make quarterbacks uncomfortable a lot I
think that's the one thing when I look
at them I just go yeah okay there's no
guy coming around the edge but there's
constantly like a guy flashing right by
the quarter Aaron Donald's busted
through oh gosh somebody else chip them
out of the way so I could step and make
a throw or Susan you know manhandling
somebody back that way
they're kind of doing what I'm saying
their defense wasn't great they missed
the corners on a few plays we're going
to go like Marcus Peters I keep Tillie
but I made that players plate yeah I
mean Peters yes played but they would
have made the play like there was a seam
route that Kirk Cousins threw down the
left sideline at one point and I was
like ah that was it keep Talib like he
might have played on that ball feelings
of ball dealin's is a deal what are they
gonna pay the own money as they give
Stefon Diggs like a 75 million dollar
contract and he's the second best
receiver on the team I mean it's
questionable I mean yes you're right I
mean but Kirk Cousins was really awesome
in that game
he made a lot of big time throws and my
big thing was the Rams are just
absolutely unstoppable on offense kid
genius has just got it all
I mean it's unreal that's what I'm
nicknaming him now that's what you're
calling McVey yeah he's kid genius where
are you getting that from
I don't know remember there was kid
dynamite and Mike Tyson growing up now
or at least I was growing up I don't you
might have still been in the womb so
this is actually interesting about the
Rams the Rams are entering the part of
their schedule that I said was going to
be the toughest okay three straight road
games two tough places to play followed
by eight by Aaron Rodgers so they go on
the road to Seattle not the toughest
team but a tough place to play
definitely on the road to Denver tough
place to play on the road to San
Francisco was a lot tougher three weeks
ago home against Aaron Rodgers to the
Saints man this is the part of the read
Seattle again then Kansas City right all
right so this is the part of the
schedule where the Rams get tougher I
expect them to do fine against Seattle
yeah they are the only team that blew
out Seattle ever in Seattle a 42 to 7
list I expect them to be fine against
the Broncos but that Aaron Rodgers game
is gonna be so freakin awesome
it will hurt because we just want his
leg to be healthy for that and we talked
about Minnesota's defense than that
right yes ok I just want to make sure we
talked about that because it still
bothers me with Mike Zimmer and the
coverage and all that like ok good as
long as he talked what was the main
thing just in case well the main thing
is just that you know there's their
defensive scheme was exposed I mean when
a 255 pounds I'm back ER is on those
three guys man-to-man like 30 yards down
the field you're you have a problem it's
not his problem it's not Anthony bars
problem it's the coach of the defense's
problem when an offensive coordinator
exposes a defense really really bad what
happens to the defense do they do they
like finally look at their cracks and
weaknesses I think so I think they start
to go we can't play this defense that
we've been playing against this
formation anymore we have to change but
like the waiting Ohio did it to
Jacksonville you said when the Niners
into Jacksonville last season you said a
lot of people won't be able to rubber I
hate this right well could people
replicate what happened to the Vikings
No
the thing it's like meghna bacon do know
he's gonna again it goes just when I say
comments like that I just go about like
I go into the elite thing again waiting
like when the Saints play em or exactly
right when you're playing some of those
high-level offensive coordinators that
understand the rules of your defense and
really know how to stress the rules
that's where zimmer I think us finally
maybe it happens this week is this
Philadelphia this week I don't even know
who's playing yet yes we companies are
playing at in Philadelphia he's gonna
look at things between last week's film
and then last year and the way your team
torched them in the NFC Championship
game easy to go I can't play these this
defense against this personnel set or
this formation anymore it's it's it's
been exposed I have to change and if he
doesn't change then then you know that
there's a problem Minnesota well it's
interesting because my heart wants me to
well not my heart my gut wants me to go
against the Eagles in that game so the
teams that went into overtime are one in
five straight up in their next game thus
far this season right we need three
overtime games here are the teams that
went to overtime last week yeah
the Texans they face Dallas on Sunday
Night Football with the David Irving
right the Colts they play the Texans
went to overtime and now play New
England on Thursday and man that's just
brutal that's brutal
not only that Sims I just saw who's
inactive for the Colts and it's Darius
Leonard as out is he out he is
questionable oh no I gotta find this cuz
it's insane to me
that is a player safety issue okay just
so for the players podcast hold on yep
oh damn it that's the list let me see
here it is Jack Doyle is out T why
Hilton is out Kenny Moore Hasan Ridgeway
Quincey Wilson Marlon Mack Denzel good
is out that's not injury related Denzel
good I believe lost his a friend or a
family member to like to he was shot
which is awful and all of our wishes go
out to him seriously Costanza was
questionable Clayton get leathers is
questionable Vinatieri is questionable
Ryan Kelly Darius Len
like look at their injury Charton it's
like 20 guys and they're playing on
Thursday Night Football in newing on the
road yeah they're in deep crap what's
the spread
I told you ten and a half that now
everybody really I think I just don't
see how that happens all right let me
finish my preview of them and then we'll
keep going but luck is quarterback as a
ten plus point underdog there one in
three and one in three against the
spread in 2017 they were on a dog of ten
or more without luck and they were Owen
five they were five times the last ten
games the Patriots as a ten plus point
favorite what do you think the record is
nine and one nine and one what do you
think they are against the spread nine
and one eight and two Tom Brady has
never lost on a short week six and oh
yeah four and two against the spray
because their inventory is just deeper
than everybody out see that's why I like
Thursday night games aren't gonna hurt
mcveigh's in the Shanahan's and the
McDaniels because they have a Rolodex of
these are our base plays but they're
rolodex is just bigger it's just bigger
they're better coaches they have more
stuff in Andrew Luck versus the Patriots
oh and five in his career
one in four against the spread Colts
defense does lead the AFC in sacks and
tackles for loss can't get off the field
and third down Julian Edelman is back
Tom Brady is making it seem like they've
never missed a beat and really if you
watch the Patriots this preseason
Edelman looked amazed they did is there
anything personal about Josh McDaniels
playing the Colts knowing that he was
the guy that was gonna be the Colts head
coach I think it's more personal in the
Colts like Chris Ballard might be down
in the coaching staff being like give it
to him this week guys but yeah I mean
it's certainly he's going to be a little
uncomfortable I mean for Josh pregame
he's gonna see people and go like damn
gosh hi hey sorry I mean yeah it's gonna
be awkward but josh is a stand-up human
being and so is Chris Ballard and I will
vouch for that
so they will handle the right way I am
I think Chris Ballard will understand I
think so too I do Chris Ballard's a yeah
pretty good dude
like the only thing you need to tell
people is I know that I told you I was
gonna take the job but there's a reason
I didn't take it right then and then
Bill Belichick called me into his office
and for the first time and his whole
life looks somebody in the eye and said
you will be the man to replace me and I
will teach you things I have not told
anybody and I think if you tell that to
anybody they're gonna go damn you're
right yes let alone a big family with
young kids at home city even Spielberg
brought me into a room and said I'm the
next great director I'm sorry I can't go
and work with you you know I mean you're
exactly right
Atlanta Cincinnati you wrote and this is
we're gonna I'm gonna do Atlanta
Cincinnati and then Pittsburgh Baltimore
okay and because then Atlanta Pittsburgh
we're just trying to explain to you that
if you don't take the over in that game
you're crazy right
I believe that Kansas City Denver was
like the largest over/under in years at
55 and I believe that this over/under is
already above that and we haven't even
gotten into midweek yet so let me
actually see if I can find that
what's the over-and-under for Kansas
City Jacksonville is big that's the
interesting one let me look him up
really quick I was teaching Nick our
beautiful audio engineer he's interested
in bedding and I try to tell him don't
get into I was do it Nick but he he's he
likes prop bets look how many sacks like
it you know what if you're a Giants fan
and there's a prop Beck for how many
times
Eli gets sacked that's a fun month
that's a fun one to mitigate the fact
that your team stinks um all right let
me see over under over under over under
oh here we go
okay the over-under for Jacksonville
Kansas City what do you think it is 41
it's currently 49 Oh
the over-under for Pittsburgh Atlanta is
what 60 58 so it's like the largest I've
seen this yeah 50 so they're expecting
like 32 28 I would be shocked all right
so let's go to Atlanta the reason we
think it's gonna be so big you wrote
Atlanta's defense is a joke holy [ __ ]
they play the same two defenses Falcons
played some two safeties heads on the
last few drives and
they actually played well and two
caressed McKinley's the only beast in
the front seven right now by the way
they're other beasts greedy Jarrett will
not be playing against Pittsburgh yes
and he must have been battling this
injury last day because he was not good
in the game either where I've kept going
like when I I actually looked at my
roster a few times like make sure like
like wait ninety seven still Grady Jared
right like I was questioning myself so
Atlanta's defenses justice we've been
waiting for two we s and it's happened I
mean the Saints to them yeah now this I
want to praise Andy Dalton the bangles
because they are doing good things cuz
they're three and one they're right and
Andy is making plays and they're moving
AJ green around and the kid Boyd's a
nice player I really feel bad for Tyler
Eifert
that was gross was it gross why I didn't
see it oh I didn't I didn't realize I
don't watch replays of injuries it was
bad I couldn't watch it when it really
happened because I knew it was bad and
then it caught me by surprise when I was
watching Phil take me through your
watching the play and I just was like oh
this the play he got hurt on and he
rolled over and you could see him
yelling like ah and I looked down at his
leg and as he was laying flat on his
back but his right foot was pointed
towards five o'clock but the rest of his
leg was straight damn Yeah right it was
disgusting oh it really bothered me um
so that's thanks for him and I feel for
him yeah I hope he has a speedy recovery
um yep anyway but anyway how kids
defense thinking stinking I mean
stinking first of all you know like we
said the scheme is way too simple the
pass rush other than McKinley there's
the only guy there that creates any
havoc so The Curious Case of Vic bezel
yeah has moments where he goes around
the edge and you go whoo that look good
but more times you're not he gets pushed
by right I don't know did he end up with
a sack the other night maybe he did end
up with a sack no take care of the
Kinley's the only one that ended up with
sex he had three of them actually so I
think that's concerning to me I still
think they lack big people and you
run on them if you decide you want to
that's why I'm excited about James
Caan's
Cincinnati decided not to run because
they were like well why would we run
everybody's open in the past game that
would makes no sense I mean I'm throwing
AJ green and nobody's within 20 feet of
them yeah so yeah there are major issues
out of the fact that true fond and
offered it is not special they're good
but they're not special and they they
act like they're special leave them on
island yeah and it's just they're not
they're not that kind of guy there's no
way they can run with the John Ross's or
the or the AJ greens or even stay with
the Boyd's of the world every play 30
snaps a game no and then of course the
scheme is simple and they've run that
Seattle scheme for the most part behind
it to cover three press bail so this is
could be an issue all year and it's
probably I don't see how it does without
Dionne Jones key Antonio or Ricardo
Allen just know I just don't see how
that happens other side you wrote
you can't play man-to-man against
Atlanta you're gonna lose one of the
three matchups you are and that would be
Julio Calvin Ridley yeah and then who's
the third new you know sanu knock he'll
win the least out of the three but he's
still good enough to where if you man
I'm up 30 times he's gonna win
he you know win his fair share and then
you got Tevin Coleman Devonta Freeman
coming back exactly right
I I saw when I watched the Cincinnati
offense first Elena defense first and I
came away going you know that was great
by Cincinnati but it was really easy and
it was like a little under well I was a
little underwhelmed and then I was like
yeah am I gonna sit here in am I gonna
watch the same thing I just people gonna
be wide open like and it's just gonna be
like holy cow no it wasn't quite like
that it was a little surprising there
were some people open here or there but
[ __ ] Matt Ryan's ballin I mean
there's just no other way to put it
that's why I officially say he's a
top-five quarterback in football for me
right now one of the the pin the the
tent poles of this podcast has been that
Matt Ryan is overrated yeah and you have
him at number four yeah I would I would
say and and I don't back down from my
previous statements of him I do think
he's been overrated as a whole for his
career but man this year other than the
Eagles game where he did wasn't great
but even last year member we talked
about last year we're like man there was
some impressive moments the stats
weren't good because it
21 touchdowns and 10 interceptions but
he had to do more by himself last year
right how you and I had those
conversations throughout the year where
we like man he made plays that's what
I'm seeing from him right now he's
making big-time throws and as the game
went on I started to go it's not ease
coverage is not that bad I mean he just
he just fitted into a tight window or he
just knew he was about to get hit and he
threw the ball into the area where he
thought the receiver should be before he
broke and damn he dropped it right in
there like that's that's all I can
really say about it he played phenomenal
sliding in the pocket running I mean he
is playing he is giving it all he's got
and that's where I'm gonna give Matt
Ryan his respect he's tough he competes
and as we talked about with the other
great quarterbacks before I judge a lot
on what you do when the world's not
perfect and he's doing a lot when the
world's not perfect and that's why I got
to give him credit can I ask you one
question as a possible reason yeah so
Matt Ryan first game was on the road
yeah outside right second third and
fourth game yeah is there any chance cuz
I've heard a lot of Atlanta Falcons fans
tell me that when he's not at home he's
a different guy
yeah could that be part of it it can be
I I mean I think it him and drew Brees
both fall into that category for me you
know I mean like drew wasn't lighting
the world on fire last week outside in
New York neither is Giants Stadium it's
kind of been their mo I don't think it's
the time of the year in Pittsburgh where
I'm worried about Matt Ryan yet like I
wouldn't go if this game was the first
week in December I do who met Ryan
outside the Falcons I'm not sure but no
I I feel pretty good about it and you
know I don't know I feel like maybe that
I think Matt Ryan's turned the corner on
that he played pretty damn good in that
playoff game up there in Philadelphia
last year you know he did enough to
where you go damn he's a baller he can
make plays so I don't know if I'd
necessarily feel that way and
Pittsburgh's got issues on defense you
also ended though you said the Bengals
linebackers is the weak spot of their
defense yeah they do get Vaughn says
perfect pac-man they need them
how are the Bengals as a whole the
bangles as a whole a mystery team they
are a mystery team their offense is
better than years past
so that's where they're gonna be
dangerous they have three weapons the
run game oh line is pretty good Oh line
pass protection at times can be a hair
shaky but still good enough what about
that defense though the defense I'm a
little disappointed in the defense okay
I'm a little disappointed Geno Atkins
has been a bright spot I feel like the
rest of the d-line has underperformed to
a degree to this point and and I I mean
I'm saying this I don't even know where
they're ranked on defense right now and
this is totally me just going off my I
okay good there 29th and football so I
feel good about that
yeah their pass rush has not been what
it's going what it should be
I don't think Dre Kirkpatrick or dork
has Denard have been as good as what
they should be William Jackson has been
their best corner this year for sure so
I guess what I'm just a little
disappointed in their day and maybe they
come around yeah someone just traded for
holy oh my league and a kid damn damn
stay focused man it's a player's podcast
we're getting offered a lot of trades by
the way cuz I went to our fantasy league
and said Odell's on the block right and
you know a lot of people want them they
do want yeah but a lot of people want
feeling I'm just gonna let everyone know
I'm not [ __ ] trading no dealings like
stat gold he's incredible I mean he's
like he is he's unreal the true thing is
what's gonna happen is we're just gonna
ride and die with juju Thielen and Odell
and we're gonna go that's our
three-headed monster yeah deal with it
we'll figure out every other position
who's our quarterback right now I just
picked up Flacco okay I like that it's
not bad I don't think that's gonna end
somebody claimed bortles off waivers oh
you wanted him yeah I thought it'd be
funny portals is our quarterback and
great especially against Kansas City
I know yeah oh very good a good day all
right last one Pittsburgh Baltimore doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
you look so cute in your little
palm-tree sweatshirt if we're gonna
start with a play Adam if we're gonna
start with Atlanta's defense let's start
with Pittsburgh Stephen right you're so
tropical you wrote zone coverage for the
Steelers suck just like the Chiefs they
lack details there are two fastest guys
in their defense are their safeties
that's not good Steelers what the [ __ ]
still playing old school cover 3 I would
attack Hayden
he holds on every play and he can't run
they're just not a good physical
tackling D self Scout you loved the
Steelers defense what are we actually
watching we're at we're I to the point
where I'm about to give up hope I don't
know if it can be turned around yeah I
mean as much as I still have hope I like
barely it's a it's a thread it's a few
threads it's like one of those palm tree
threads in your sweat your optical
threads um I don't even know where to
sit yes I was impressed with them in the
preseason and the preseason they were
having moments of just pure physical
dominance but that's why yeah you just
got to be careful about the preseason
there Dean line is not the Wreckers that
we've known to love to it and Hayward
not reckon not reckon not horrible it's
it's solid but it's not wrecking you
know the linebacker thing is an issue
there you know bud Dupree and wot have
spots in moments but it's not enough and
the corner play is an issue it is I mean
what about all the athletes yeah I mean
the athletes Sean Davis is athletic
Artie burns does he have an injury that
he's dealing with right now I know that
they pulled him in he wasn't starting
but I think that was based on plane yeah
I mean it's not it's not pretty I know
that um yeah there are two most
explosive people when I watch film are
the first-round pick at Edmonds and Sean
Davis they can run all over the field
when they open up and I'm not saying
they're perfect fix this any time I
don't see it I don't think they can play
man-to-man cam Sutton sensible if
already Burns is in there RT has
certainly not been as good as he should
be as a first-round pick Joe Hayden just
can't flat-out run anymore he doesn't
have the six gear make one great play he
did on the deep post down the middle
right that was incredible but there was
a whole lot of other teams where he was
beat deep too and he does hold a little
and I'm not saying he's Orlando
Scandrick so don't want anybody to think
it's like to that level but for Joe
Hayden who's a corner that's probably
making I don't know 13 14 million a year
12 whatever it is yeah he's not living
up to his end of the bargain
Pittsburgh's off
what I meant by cover three just real
quick like cover three and 1998 is not
the same as covered three now okay what
do you mean covered three and 1998 was
like if you're the down safety you just
drop and go into this area and you know
if you're this linebacker you got the
curl flat area over here or just drop no
now it's more about route reading to
where they're not just gonna let like
some guy come through their zone and
like be like oh I'm just supposed to sit
here because coach wrote the circle
there's more matchups it matches up more
in the NFL now because offenses become
too creative you can't just go over to
play the curl flat people got 9 million
different combinations of routes in the
curl flat area now they're doing the
tradition they're doing the traditional
and I'm gonna be like are you kidding me
like III bet you Joe Flacco hasn't
played against traditional cover 3 since
he was in like New Jersey high school
football game like it's that ridiculous
mmm interesting yeah Pittsburgh's
offense and we'll do Baltimore's offense
and defense after this not really great
in the running game the offensive line
you don't think James Connor can do
anything by himself now the play calling
though you wrote the Steelers offense is
not as creative they don't move a
Antonio Brown around as much more
outside than years past yes and you
wondered I wonder if been mrs. Todd
Haley hmm I mean Todd I watched
Cleveland and Baker Mayfield and they
get a little everything shots down the
field all different personnel sets
people being moved around screens power
run game it's all cool Pittsburgh right
now I just feel like there's really no
power run game anymore with levy on bail
there was moments I know we all think
it's just a spread out football team you
know they would get into like two tight
ends and we're gonna run downhill and
run inside outside zone and I feel like
they would do that 15 to 20 times again
they don't really do that anymore and
then the past game yes the the concepts
and the past game are not as creative
they are putting our man a be outside
more where he used to get like we used
to talk about the advantage he had over
Odell would be in the bunch sets and the
sack sets and he always got these great
creative ways none of that's happening
and he's getting frustrated the guy
that's only getting the ball on a
consistent basis and that offenses juju
and that's because he's getting to work
the middle
feels more times than not and it's an
issue the connection between Ben and a
Antonio Brown and so off that Tomlin's
having to comment on it that it's gonna
be fine I know it to me it looks like a
Antonio Browns running the wrong route
sometimes I guess Ben's the one getting
super frustrated yeah Antonio is the one
walking off the field I think it's
happened a few times I think on Monday
night it was Ben saw I think yeah Monday
night was the Ravens right or Sunday
night sorry it was the oh yeah but the
Monday night game if there was a few
where I would have gone I think that was
a bee he messed when I write this game I
think a lot of the frustration more been
missed some throws in the second half
where I just don't know he had one where
he just sailed it yeah Wow tonio Brown a
third down exactly was a great Drive
they had Ryan Switzer in there a bunch
was a lot of quick outs I was like and I
remember watching the gaming going this
is the new Steelers yeah five wide stay
up with us and then he just overthrew
Antonio around a third down the drive
was over than Baltimore at the ball back
and it was game it was over exactly
right he missed that then they got the
ball back the next series he had Antonio
Brown open on an in cut on the third
down and I mean he's gonna be open if he
hits it him and stride it's gonna be
another 15 or 20 yards at least and I
love betting on the Steelers after a
game like that like that you when they
play bad and then Tomlin gets in their
ass and they're just and then Ben comes
back the next day he's like I'm gonna
throw 500 a chest Atlanta the one thing
I've never questioned about the Steelers
is their tackling and physical dominance
that's and this is the first time I'm
questioning that that's what's weird to
me Mike Tomlin prides himself on being a
tough guy they practice and pads all
summer they hit all summer that's what
people who have to play Pittsburgh early
in the season like that's what they
worry about like when I went to training
camp in Pittsburgh a few years ago
remember that two summers ago and then I
went to the Redskins the next few days
later and Jay Gruden had to play the
Steelers in the first week it's all you
want to know with a tackling were they
hitting a lot like he was concerned cuz
he's like I don't want to they might
have physical US and that's what they've
always been able to do and be the bully
on the field and now they're not even
the bully right now so when you're not
the bully and then you're being out
schemed and creative then you're in
trouble you do
think though that one guy's a bully you
wrote and I tweeted this out so I don't
know if you saw my tweet no euro Vance
McDonald might be the new Grunk so I
said I said he's baby Grunk good do you
so you think that Vance McDonald do you
think you said he might be or is he I
think he's on his way there he's the
only other tight end in football that
you know how I love to always say this
he's the only other tight end in
football right now I just guess the ball
is like or get out of our way I'm not
like gonna fall down and not let you
trip me up like I'm coming to destroy
you and then he take off his help I mean
his face he's got like chiseled steel I
swear he's Ivan Drago of like the
Irishman okay look up his picture it's
unbelievable
he is like this big square head diamond
face guy that's like it's like I'm
Captain America I remember he was great
with San Francisco oh yeah his jaws
insane insane but he is a guy that's
looking to punish people
he's got like a quagmire jaw is that
well what does that have my guy oh
you're right you know like the super
what giggity-giggity
yes but he is really does impress me I
mean to be that big to run the way he
does the the the the absolute just you
know physicality he uses when he has the
ball in his hand now Tony Jefferson that
was an awesome play to start the games
oh just amazing but the Ravens got some
badass mofos too
alright so let's talk about the Ravens
and we'll start wrapping it up yeah
Baltimore's offense John Brown ran right
by Sutton and Hayden for Pittsburgh for
a touchdown why because those guys
aren't fast you think the pass
protection for the Ravens has been great
the o-line is special you couldn't get
near Joe that that's what gets concerned
to me like there's one thing about sacs
yeah because Cincinnati was all over Joe
I know that one game is the outlier
right now for Baltimore I don't know
they all must hit the ball in the night
before I don't know what the hell they
did that because the Thursday night
Baltimore in the first game blew out
Buffalo third game really controlled
Denver the entire time yeah and Denver's
a good team yes and then yeah the
Cincinnati game that was the one time
where it was scary Flacco
being mobile getting chased down and
yeah it and right throwing stupid balls
in the air yeah all that yeah
no their old line you said they're
special they change up personal
informations they're aggressive and you
said could you imagine if the Ravens had
a good running back yeah
you're not a big fan of Alex Collins oh
I mean he's solid but he's not a
difference-maker
Julius Allen yeah good like tough
they're gonna they're gonna get tough
yards which I respect about them but
they go into the class of the guys that
like we always talk about where if
there's ten yards in there you know they
might get 11 or 12 every now and then
but like the good running backs in
football when there's ten yards there
you know half those times they end up
getting 20 or 30 and they never do that
the defense so you you're very confident
in the bet of the Ravens they went like
that the other thing they did that I
thought was cool Lamar Jackson coming in
the game like our Tolton Colt the guy
for the Saints Taysom Hill they had that
little wrinkle to right which makes
sense morning Whigs from the that whole
school - but I'm not high on Lamar right
now no you don't you don't even look
fast no he does not look as fast as
Lamar when I look at his body me being a
professional looker of naked men he
looks a little top-heavy right now like
somebody's telling him you need to be
bigger it's the NFL and he has
definitely lost a step to where he was
Plus - like what my dad said before like
you don't run as much in the NFL it's on
you to run they don't run you every day
like in college whether she played for
the patron right exam last you play for
the Patriots but the cool thing they did
there when they brought him in they took
the right tackle Jame Hurst out and they
put our guy Orlando Brown in and he
dissed they were like we're gonna run
behind that big guy and he would push
everybody down I don't they just play
them every time I I'm sure they're
probably a little worried about his past
Pro is feeder or like a hair slow and
James horse is good so you're saying
Orlando Brown run blocking though is a
thing like I think you're gonna continue
to see them start to do these heavy sets
where they bring an extra tight end but
it's Orlando Brown you shoot they're
playing what tight ends at left guard
yeah that was really cool too they were
in spider 2 y banana but he was at guard
he was at right guard was a left guard
right guard left guard yes
which
again like people like I know people in
our office Reich is that legal yeah it
was legal it's a legal formation it's
odd you couldn't do that all the time
you're gonna get killed if they do that
but if they throw that wrinkle in there
once a game once every few weeks that'll
piss people off I'm feeling much better
about my Baltimore being the number one
seed in the AFC you should I'm feeling
good about Dallas right now a little bit
better than I was yes there's things to
like about it but there's definitely
some tea like my Texans pick I am not
liking ya
Baltimore's defense though you wrote
something that I was very surprised
you wrote the Baltimore's defense is
creative it's detailed and it has
killers yeah and you said that tavon
young Anthony Levine yes and Marlin
Humphrey are difference-makers right you
were not a believer in Marlin Humphrey I
was not coming on the draft I thought
that year he was I thought he was like
what fourth or fifth I might a lot of
people had him at number one or number
two right
what is he showing you that you didn't
see at Alabama I think just a little bit
better straightaway speed that I saw at
Alabama and his ability to get up in
people's face and change direction with
an Antonio Brown yeah you wrote that he
had no problem with Antonio Brown man
yeah moments where they just said go out
there Antonio's on the left side it's
you and him big boy by the way Jimmy
Smith is back this week all right
so that so now the Baltimore Ravens are
gonna be that much bright haven young
didn't pie last year so he was a really
good nickel for them his rookie year the
year before so guys like the anthing
levine I believe battled some injuries
last year this kid yeah he's been around
there okay and he's been filling in but
he's not like a guy that you would know
unless you're like you know watching
film like me or whatever but he adds yes
toughness good like can be the big
nickel can be the third safety type of
guy depends on how you want to match him
up that way but like little guys like
that make it a little big difference in
like taking your defense temir being
number 10 in football to number 2 like
where they are right now and I think
that's what I like about them so you're
really fueling the Ravens man the Ravens
are removable so when I listen to you
and I think about all the teams
I go obviously super high on the Rams I
think they're the team that your highest
on it go do your Power Rankings they're
probably number what they are number one
super high on the Chiefs right I got a
lot of questions but they're not my
number two Baltimore
top bottom looking great I really like
them Saints top bottom looking great
you're really confident in them who else
are the team who's your number two
Jacksonville Jacksonville yeah I'm not
giving up my Jacksonville just cuz they
laid an egg on Tennessee and the New
England's always in the top six yeah
exactly should be there in those are the
top five six teams I think that you're
most confident on I think so I think the
Bears are close in that conversation so
it would be it would be Rams Chiefs Jack
this is no order yeah so Rams Jaguars
Chiefs Ravens Patriots Saints right
Chicago yeah yeah I think Chicago's in
like that's your top seven Chicago has
shown me that they can win different
ways you know that's a big thing to me
to like when you're when your fastball
isn't working do you have two other
pitches that you can rely on yeah can I
give you one piece of advice yeah sure
sure master before you crown them
realize that they've beaten Seattle
Tampa on the road at Arizona yeah I know
so like that's Arizona on the road tamp
at home I get you oh we got you but I
look at the other teams and I go man the
Saints have battled some really good
offense you're writing really good teams
you're right the Bears are the only team
that I'm looking at and I also want to
say that the Bears against the Bucks
defense and and Mike Smith I know
Mitchell sure Biscay is gonna get a lot
more pressure valid valid questions
that's my only that's my only stuff
before we crown the Chicago because I do
not believe that they're in the top but
I do think that their defenses in the -
yeah oh yeah I guess I would not put
them in the class of the guys you know I
said that next year the next year yeah
yeah yeah
last thing your top five is Rogers
mahomes Wentz Matt Ryan Tom Brady that I
couldn't believe that last thing I
really just sitting there frustrated
over this I can't believe that I was
asked to make a list and week four I
wasn't I would never ask you to do I
know you and I was like oh my god are
you kidding me it's been four weeks and
they want me to tell me they say no I
know but I'm a team player I try to be
and yeah as i sat there i just like damn
Matt Ryan's Matt Ryan's top five I can't
I can't just be a hater and you have
Jared golf at number twelve right which
I think people probably thinks crazy but
I think that's like you have him below
Cam Newton
Russell Wilson Kirk Cousins Drew Brees
Phillip Rivers and Big Ben yeah
he's he can make another jump my only
thing with Jared Goff is going back to
our start of the conversation when we
talked about my homes and some of the
other great quarterbacks what can he do
when it's not there for him perfect the
last two weeks two and a half weeks then
perfect he showed me things like I've
been like damn there's nothing there and
he made it happen I like that but that's
been the first time I've seen that just
looking at you right now I'm kind of
thinking maybe Brees is a little low I'm
kind of thinking that Russell Wilson's
an interesting one it is an interesting
one he's an interest I don't feel like
breezes low I feel very good about that
again I think where youdo this is your
list I know give me my I just think
we're taking you know again the Saints
it's a special oh it's a special team
that they have there so ten and a half
last night super Steve he went with the
Patriots - ten and a half goo busty and
you're agreeing with him I am I got to
go with him I wanted to go against Scuba
Steve but yeah sorry yeah I might bet a
lot of money on that tomorrow Thursday
Night Football a football and one team
played five quarters of football and the
other team played three quarters one of
them is coached by Bill Belichick the
others a first-year head coach exactly
yeah thank you for letting us unload our
notebook as always hit us up at Sims and
Lefko Instagram or Twitter whether it's
the DMS or just a comment or a message
happy to have you we should have Josh
vendrick back tomorrow
good the bank for a betting show did not
overly talk about banking so uh the
betting so they it really stresses me
the this betting show I just I stem it
all back to this I went and saw IRA and
IRAs been listening to our podcast for a
long time and he was are better for the
show yeah and he said Adam I don't know
how you guys do it I said what do you
mean he goes I only had to pick Rams
Vikings and I tossed and turned all
night
you guys have to pick 16 games dude it's
crazy I just feel like my advice to you
is this yeah everybody else right there
is a thought process where
procrastination is actually good where
you start thinking about something and
you purposely put it on the back burner
to let your brain work through it it's
called like divergent thinking right I
tried it last week it felt good think
about it a little bit tonight write down
a little bit of notes sleep on it wake
up in the morning then make your picks
yeah I think you're right try it that's
that's what frustrates me about it wise
you're gonna be because I feel like I'm
so into last week still yes and then oh
I don't even know who's planning each
other yeah I know I know but I always
feel like damn I'm cheating the fans
because on Saturday Friday night I come
up with things I'm like oh I should have
thought about that law if you just text
me we'll put it out on to it okay go
against it was the left go for sin
peace out homies vendrick would say good
evening and the lef koe man says holla
holla holla at this shirt holla holla
holla holla see in Hawaii